Physician satisfaction with the EHR is an extremely important topic,
and one that will have widespread ramifications
for the effort to use Health Informatics as
a tool for establishing
a learning health care system and effectively using the new knowledge it creates.
In 2013, The Rand Corporation and the American Medical Association published what I
believe to be the best study today on
overall physician satisfaction including satisfaction with the EHRs.
The survey team selected 30 physician practices to achieve a good cross-section.
Each practice completed a structured questionnaire that included
questions about its electronic health record use and capabilities,
and participation in innovative payment models.
The survey team then visited these practice and conducted
semi structured interviews with 220 informants.
Finally, they surveyed 656 physicians in the 30 practices receiving 447 responses,
a 68 percent response rate.
Here are the results with respect to satisfaction with the practices EHR.
The majority of physicians believe the EHR
improves care quality but using it is inefficient of their time.
Interestingly, only 18 percent of
the physicians indicated they would revert to paper records if they could.
Disturbingly, according to the American Academy of Family Practice,
the AAFP, a strong advocate of the EHRs,
physician satisfaction with them is declining.
As our baseline in the AAFP 2010 survey,
61 percent of respondents said they were satisfied or very satisfied with the EHRs.
American EHR partners is a new effort supported by 20 professional societies including
the AAFP and the American College of Physicians
another large physician group that advocates for EHRs.
American EHR has been collecting data since the AAFP survey in 2010,
and it claims theirs is the only EHR survey that
charts satisfaction over time and allows for the benchmarking of data.
Today, American EHR says it has collected over 7500 responses using the same core survey.
They say this allows them to have comprehensive breakdowns by specialty,
practice size, EHR type and so on.
The American EHR partners 2014 online survey of 940 physicians found that
42 percent thought their EHR systems ability
to improve efficiency was difficult or very difficult.
72 percent thought their EHR system's ability
to decrease workload was difficult or very difficult.
54 percent found their EHR system increased their total operating costs,
and 43 percent said they had yet to overcome
the productivity challenges related to their EHR system.
However, over 36,000 physicians received invitations.
So the response rate was only two point six percent.
It is certainly possible that
dissatisfied physicians were more motivated to express those feelings,
a phenomenon known as response bias.
I asked the American EHR about this and they say that
the 2014 results are actually
consistent with results they've been continuing to receive since then.
In any case, it seems clear that physicians
find the use of an EHR inefficient and challenging.
We next turn to why this is the case.